on a un coup de coeur de gilles verdez
vas-y mon chéri j'ai un coup de coeur
très émue pour deux nonagénaires qui
s'appelle qui se prénomme monique et
henry qui ont été tous les deux malades
du courant navires us hospitalisés les
deux et puis là ils sont sortis
c'est à l'hôpital bichat qu'un hôpital
magnifique et ils ont rendu hommage à
leurs soignants je trouve ça d'une
émotion fort quoi c'est une magnifique
histoire d'amour ça m'a beaucoup touché
ils ont 88 et 90 cents a indiqué henry
et regardez ils étaient touchés du coup
par le coran d'un virus était samedi
soir au 20 heures de france 2 c'est
parti c'est là c'est l'amour l'amour n'a
pas d'âge
l'amour n'a pas de frontières voilà
hongrie c'est ce qu'on appelle une bonne
nouvelle dans cette période où les
informations sont pour le moins
anxiogène
hier france 2 nous présenter un couple
de retraités qui malgré leur infection
au coronavirus ont réussi à guérir si on
sait que ce virus touche de façon
particulièrement difficile les personnes
plus âgées
voici une preuve que rien est
inéluctable à 90 ans henri marché est un
homme plutôt en bonne santé mais lorsque
sa température commence à monter et
qu'ils éprouvent des difficultés pour
respirer il se rend en urgence à
l'hôpital bichat à paris c'est là qu'il
est tout de suite pris en charge
rejoints quelques jours plus tard par
monique sa compagne de 88 ans elle aussi
testée positive au co vite 19 malgré les
prédictions le couple est sorti indemne
de cette épreuve
henry et monique sont aujourd'hui hors
de danger et ont pu regagner leur
domicile le coeur léger
aujourd'hui il témoigne de la prise en
charge exceptionnelle dont ils ont
bénéficié
on a été soignée d'une façon
exceptionnelle
bah oui oui leur époustouflant un couple
adorable qui nous redonne du sourire et
de l'espoir
[Musique]
ouais ça nous donne de l'espoir à clapet
dit rien alors on va voir j'aimerais
qu'on voit un petit peu le lot
témoignages qu'on voit le témoignage
d'henri et monique un peu plus long
parce que c'est vrai que ça nous donne
tellement d'espoir témoin clé et voilà
les fonctions voilà ils sont ils ont eu
recours aux navires ils s'en sont sortis
hissel
ils ont 88 et 90 ans est vrai et voilà
mon fins et fatou et gilles dandin dix
ans dans dix ans je suis imaginé dans
dix ans à 90 ans henri marché n'est
jamais malade alors qu'en fin février
ils commencent à se sentir un peu
fiévreux il ne s'inquiète pas
pendant quelques jours c'était toujours
du ca frôlé les 38 chanceuse pas d'être
vraiment mais les symptômes s'aggravent
avec des problèmes respiratoires
il faut appeler le samu henri est placé
plusieurs jours sous oxygène mais pas en
réanimation une bataille menée aux côtés
de son épouse dépistée positive elle
aussi quand j'ai su que j'étais positif
ça vraiment ça n'a rien fait parce qu'on
m'a dit vous allez aller dans la chambre
à deux lits avec votre époux ont été
retrouvés tous les deux voilà combat
gagné samedi dernier trois jours après
sa femme
henry sort de l'hôpital henri voilà on
leur souhaite beaucoup de bonheur la
raison est bien sûr le beau fauteuil la
soirée laisser la femme sur la chaîne al
droe tina et c'est ce qu'ils digéraient
vous plaît